Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That am a Spartan queen. I come to tell you a story. A story unlike any that has been told before. It is the story of the greatest war ever fought. Years had lasted. Famous cities went up in flames. Mighty heroes, the pride of Greece and Asia, won undying glory for themselves. Some died before their time and their shades fled down to the underworld. Others, when the war was done, met with equally unhappy fates. One, returning from the war, was murdered in his own palace.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。我曾是一位斯巴达女王。我来给你们讲一个故事。一个前所未闻的故事。这是关于曾经打过的最伟大战争的故事。这场战争持续了多年。著名的城市付之一炬。伟大的英雄们——希腊和亚洲的傲慢，为自己赢得了不朽的荣耀。有些人在天年未到时便死去，他们的魂魄逃入冥界；另一些人在战争结束后，遇到了同样不幸的命运。其中一人在从战争归来时，在自己的宫殿里被谋杀。
Another, a man of tricks and turns, the great schemer who did more than anyone else to secure victory for the Greeks, roams the world to this day. Who knows if he will ever make it home? I too, in the years since the war, have roamed the world. I have spoken to those who fought and survived. I have toured the fields and sailed the waters where the battles were decided. I have sought to understand everything that happened, how it was that East and West came to go to war. I played my own small part.
另一个人，一个诡计多端、足智多谋的人，这个为希腊人争取胜利出了最大力的人，至今仍在世间流浪。谁知道他是否能回到家乡呢？自战争以来的这些年里，我也在世间流浪。我与那些战斗并幸存下来的人交谈过。我游历了决定战争胜负的战场，航行过那些水域。我试图了解所发生的一切，了解东西方是如何走向战争的。我也尽了自己的一份微薄之力。
I will tell you how. But this is not just my story. It is the story of everyone who played a part, gods as well as men. A story unlike any you will ever have read. So that, Tom Holland, as you well know, is the beginning of the book The Wolf Girl, The Greeks and the Gods by, would you believe, Tom Holland yourself. You've basically persuaded me to read out your own book to you. I did.
我会告诉你我是如何做到的。但这不仅是我的故事，也是每一个参与者的故事，包括神明和人类。这是一个你从未读过的故事。所以，汤姆·霍兰，正如你所知，这就是《狼女孩：希腊人与诸神》这本书的开端，作者是，你信不信，就是你本人，汤姆·霍兰。你基本上说服了我把您自己的书读给您听。我确实这么做了。
This is a podcast about Herodotus, the father of history. We could have started with Herodotus, but you've chosen to start with Holland. Explain yourself, Tom. Shameless self-promotion. So the premise of this book is that Gorgo, who is mentioned in Herodotus, the first great historian. In fact, the first historian, full stop. There was no Herodotus before Herodotus, the first great historian. In fact, the first historian, full stop. There was no Herodotus before Herodotus is the famous maxim. And in this book, he introduces a Spartan princess called Gorgo, who is the daughter of a Spartan king called Cleomenes,
这是一个关于历史之父希罗多德的播客。我们本可以从希罗多德开始，但你却选择从霍兰开始。解释一下吧，汤姆。无耻的自我宣传。所以这本书的前提是，希罗多德（第一位伟大的历史学家，事实上，也是第一位历史学家，句号。在希罗多德之前没有希罗多德，第一位伟大的历史学家，事实上，也是第一位历史学家，句号。在希罗多德之前没有希罗多德，这是著名的格言）中提到的戈尔戈。在这本书中，他引入了一位名叫戈尔戈的斯巴达公主，她是斯巴达国王克里昂米尼斯的女儿，
and who will go on to marry another Spartan king called Leonidas, the king who in due course will die at the Battle of Thermopylae. She is the heroine in my children's book and plays key parts in various parts of the story, but she's also embodying this desire to explain what happened in the war, but also why the war happened, and even more than that, the infinite quality of the world in which he's living. So the world of the Greeks, but also the world of the Persians who are invading Greece. There's a twofold echo in that introduction. So the first echo is an echo of Homer. Yes.
她后来嫁给另一位斯巴达国王列奥尼达，也就是日后将在温泉关战役中阵亡的国王。她是我儿童书中的女主角，在故事的各个部分扮演着关键角色，但她也体现了这样一种愿望：解释发生了什么战争，还要解释为什么会发生这场战争，甚至更进一步，展现他所生活的那个世界的无限性。希腊人的世界，以及入侵希腊的波斯人的世界。这段引言中有双重回响。第一个回响是荷马的回响。是的。
So the story of great cities being burnt, of kings coming back from the wars and being murdered. The trickster who wanders the earth. Cunning tricksters, yes. So you might think that that's Troy. You might think that that's Agamemnon, the Greek king, who comes back to Mycenae and is murdered by Cytomnestra. You might think that that's Odysseus. But in fact, the cities in my version that gets burnt is Athens,
因此，伟大城市被烧毁，国王从战争中归来被谋杀的故事。在世间流浪的骗子。狡猾的骗子，是的。所以你可能会认为那是特洛伊。你可能会认为那是希腊国王阿伽门农，他回到迈锡尼被克吕泰涅斯特拉谋杀。你可能会认为那是奥德修斯。但事实上，在我的版本中被烧毁的城市是雅典，
gets burnt by the Persians in 480 BC. The king who returns home and is murdered is Xerxes, the Persian king who gets killed in a palace coup. And the man of many tricks and parts who secures victory for the Greeks is Themistocles, the great Athenian admiral at the Battle of Salamis, who basically wins that decisive naval engagement. So there is that echo, but there is also an echo of Herodotus, who at the beginning of his great work kind of talks in similar terms to Gorgo in the version that I've just given. So I will read the first line of the first work of history ever written,
公元前480年被波斯人烧毁。凯旋归来却被谋杀的国王是波斯国王薛西斯，他在一场宫廷政变中被杀。而那个为希腊人争取胜利的诡计多端的人是特米斯托克利，萨拉米斯战役中伟大的雅典海军统帅，他基本上赢得了那场决定性的海战。所以有这样的回响，但也有希罗多德的回响，他在其伟大著作的开篇，以类似于我刚才给出的版本中戈尔戈的口吻在说话。所以我要朗读有史以来第一部历史著作的第一行，
where Herodotus announces himself and his purpose. You're not going to read it in Greek, are you, Tom? You're going to read it in a lovely translation. Who's the author of this translation, may I ask? Me. Me. So this is the Penguin Classics. The most egotistical podcast ever recorded this episode.
希罗多德在那里宣布了自己和他的意图。你不会用希腊语读吧，汤姆？你要用一个可爱的译本读。请问这个译本的作者是谁？我。我。所以这是企鹅经典。这期播客是史上最自负的播客。
I know, I know, I know, I know. But it is quite a good translation, though, I say it myself. So here we go. Herodotus from Halicarnassus here displays his inquiries that human achievement may be spared the ravages of time and that everything great and astounding and all the glory of those exploits which serve to display Greeks and barbarians alike to such effect be kept alive. And additionally, and most importantly, to give the reason they went to war. So Tom, when he talks about the glory of those exploits, am I right in saying, I read that you had, in your translation of that, you have given a little nod to Homer there,
我知道，我知道，我知道，我知道。但即使是我自己说，这也是一个相当不错的译本。所以我们开始吧。来自哈利卡纳苏斯的希罗多德在此展示他的调查研究，以便让人类的成就免受时间的摧残，并使所有伟大惊人的事物以及那些用来充分展示希腊人和蛮族风采的功绩的光芒得以长存。此外，最重要的是，给出他们开战的原因。所以汤姆，当他谈到这些功绩的光芒时，我说得对吗，我读到你在那段翻译中，对荷马致以了一点敬意，
that you could have translated that differently. But because the talk of glory and all that sort of stuff is some kind of nod to the Iliad, is that right? Yeah. So Herodotus there is absolutely echoing the Iliad. So Troy is mentioned, but actually Herodotus, when he's trying to explain how it is that the peoples of Asia and the peoples of Europe have gone to war, he lists the Trojan War, but he goes back even further. And he says that according to the Persians, it's the fault of the Phoenicians who are the naval power in what's now Lebanon, who are subjects of the Persians, who form the core of the great fleet that gets defeated at Salamis. And the Persians say that the Phoenicians came and they abducted a princess of Argos, and that this led to a kind of tit-for-tat princess rustling. The Trojans then come and
你本可以把那段翻译得不同。但是因为关于荣耀之类的谈话某种程度上是对《伊利亚特》的致敬，是这样的吗？是的。所以希罗多德在那里绝对是在呼应《伊利亚特》。因此提到了特洛伊，但实际上希罗多德在试图解释亚洲民族和欧洲民族如何开战时，他列举了特洛伊战争，但他回溯得更远。他说，根据波斯人的说法，这是腓尼基人的错，腓尼基人是现在黎巴嫩地区的海军强国，他们是波斯人的臣民，构成了在萨拉米斯被击败的那支宏大舰队的核心。波斯人说腓尼基人来绑架了一位阿尔戈斯的公主，这导致了一种针锋相对的抢公主行为。然后特洛伊人来
nick Helen, and so it goes on, and it's just kind of escalated and escalated and escalated. Basically, Herodotus' account, his inquiries, and that's what hysteria means. The word history comes from it, means researches, it means inquiries. It's an enormous shaggy dog story because just when you think that he's going to go into kind of details about how it is that, say, the Persians become part of this story, he doesn't. He's going off on an absolute kind of, going massively off piste. And he starts to talk about a king who wants his bodyguard to have a peek at his queen while she's naked. Yeah, very famous.
拐走了海伦，事情就这样继续下去，不断升级，升级，再升级。基本上，希罗多德的记述、他的调查（这也是“历史”这个词的含义，历史这个词来源于它，意思是研究、调查）。这是一个巨大的、冗长乏味的故事，因为正当你以为他要开始详细讲述比如波斯人是如何成为这个故事的一部分时，他却没有。他完全偏离了方向，大规模地跑题了。他开始谈论一个国王，想让他的保镖看一眼他裸体的王后。是的，非常著名。
And the consequences of that are fatal. And then before you know it, you've got a story about a guy who's been a musician who's been captured by pirates and he escapes them by jumping into a sea while he's playing his lute and he lands on a dolphin and gets taken to dry land. And so it goes on and so it goes on. And you realize that this is a kind of great compilation of stories and wonders. And if it looks forward to history, it also looks forward to, I don't know, the Arabian Nights or great collections of short stories. So that's the wonderful thing about Herodotus and why he is not just my favourite historian, but I think my favourite writer, is that he is both a great historian and infinitely entertaining. All right. Well, Tom, before we get into the weeds, so let's take a step back and look at the sort of broad context. So you said there's no Herodotus before Herodotus.
而这造成的后果是致命的。接着在你还没反应过来之前，你听到了一个故事：一个音乐家被海盗俘虏了，他一边弹奏着里拉琴一边跳进海里逃跑，落在一只海豚背上，被带到了陆地上。事情就这样继续下去，继续下去。你意识到这是一个关于故事和奇迹的宏大汇编。如果它面向未来（历史），它也面向未来，比如《一千零一夜》或伟大的短篇小说集。所以这就是希罗多德奇妙的地方，为什么他不仅是我最喜欢的历史学家，也是我最喜欢的作家，因为他既是一位伟大的历史学家，又极其引人入胜。好了。好吧，汤姆，在我们深入细节之前，让我们退一步，看看大致的背景。你刚才说在希罗多德之前没有希罗多德。
So the father of history, we are in the 5th century BC. Herodotus is obviously writing in Greek and sees himself as Greek, but he's not from what we would conventionally see as Greece, is he? He's from Halicarnassus, which is now Bodrum in Turkey. Yes, the great yachting centre. Yes, exactly. So give us a sense of what we know about Herodotus, the man and his times. Well, we know very little about his biography because people in his age simply weren't interested in recording details like that. Herodotus is essentially the first person who is putting down penned biographies of people, and he doesn't do it for himself. So we can tell from that opening that he does come from this place, Halicarnassus,
作为历史之父，我们身处公元前5世纪。希罗多德显然是用希腊语写作，并视自己为希腊人，但他并不是来自我们传统上认为的希腊，对吧？他是来自哈利卡纳苏斯，也就是现在土耳其的博德鲁姆。是的，那个伟大的游艇中心。是的，完全正确。那么请为我们大致讲讲我们对希罗多德这位以及他所处时代的了解。嗯，我们对他的生平知之甚少，因为他那个时代的人根本对记录这些细节不感兴趣。希罗多德基本上是第一个为人撰写生平传记的人，而他并没有为自己写。所以我们可以从那个开篇看出他确实来自这个地方，哈利卡纳苏斯，
which was founded by settlers from the Peloponnese. So that's the little, you know, the kind of the fork that constitutes Southern Greece. And they cross the Aegean to the Asian side of the Aegean. And they come to the Asian side of the Aegean and they come to a place called Caria, which is basically the kind of the southwest corner of what's now Turkey. If we want any kind of information about biographical information about Herodotus, we actually have to go to the 10th century AD. So there's a Byzantine encyclopedia. Oh, yes. The Suda. The Suda, the fortress, as it's called. This is a millennium and a half after Herodotus lives.
它是由来自伯罗奔尼撒半岛的定居者建立的。也就是那个小小的，你知道的，构成希腊南部的那个分叉。他们穿过爱琴海来到爱琴海的亚洲一侧。他们来到爱琴海的亚洲一侧，来到一个叫卡利亚的地方，基本上就是现在土耳其的西南角。如果我们想获得关于希罗多德生平的任何信息，我们实际上不得不去公元10世纪查找。所以有一部拜占庭百科全书。哦，是的。《苏达辞书》。《苏达辞书》，也就是所谓的要塞。这发生在希罗多德生活的千纪半之后。
And there we get the detail that his father was called Lyxes and his uncle was called Paniasis. And apparently these are names that are essentially Carian, which imply either that Herodotus is kind of Grico-Carian or that the Greeks have become sufficiently Carianized that they're adoptingaryan names. Either way, it points to a sense that Herodotus is inherently cosmopolitan. He is Greek. He is part of the Karyan world. More broadly, he's part of the world of Anatolia. Anatolia and Halicarnassus with it has been conquered by the Persians. When Herodotus is born, presumably sometime in the 480s BC, he's born a subject of the Persian king. And to be a subject of the Persian king is to be aware of yourself as part of a dominion that is
在那里我们得到了这样的细节：他的父亲叫利克西斯，他的叔叔叫帕尼亚西斯。显然，这些名字本质上是卡利亚语，这意味着要么希罗多德是希腊-卡利亚混血，要么希腊人已经充分卡利亚化，以至于他们采用了卡利亚语的名字。无论哪种方式，它都表明希罗多德天生具有世界主义色彩。他是希腊人。他是卡利亚世界的一部分。更广泛地说，他是安纳托利亚世界的一部分。安纳托利亚及其哈利卡纳苏斯已被波斯人征服。当希罗多德出生时（大概在公元前480年代的某个时候），他出生时就是波斯国王的臣民。成为波斯国王的臣民意味着意识到自己是一个庞大帝国的组成部分，
huge beyond the dreams of any previous conqueror. So Herodotus is born on the westernmost edge of an empire that stretches all the way to India and the Hindu Kush. That means, I think, that compared to Thucydides, the other great historian who will follow Herodotus, Thucydides is born in Athens and his perspective is a very Greek one. He's not really interested in anything beyond the purlieus of Greece. Herodotus has an inherently more global scale of interests. His history, when he says that his aim is to record the glory of those exploits, which serve to display Greeks and barbarians alike to such effect, because the Persians essentially rule the whole of Asia, and from
其规模超出了任何先前征服者的梦想。所以希罗多德出生在一个帝国的最西端，这个帝国一直延伸到印度和兴都库什山脉。我认为这意味着，与修昔底德（继希罗多德之后的另一位伟大历史学家）相比，修昔底德出生在雅典，他的视角非常希腊化。他实际上对希腊边陲之外的任何事物都不感兴趣。希罗多德拥有一种天生更加全球化的兴趣规模。他的历史，当他说他的目标是记录那些功绩的光芒，这些功绩充分展示了希腊人和蛮族时，因为波斯人基本上统治了整个亚洲，从
Herodotus' perspective, much of Africa, that means that Herodotus' subject is basically the entire world because he sees it as a world war. I mean, it isn't. For the Persians, it's a kind of peripheral border skirmish, really. But Herodotus frames it as being this great war between Europe and Asia. And this therefore justifies him in writing not just history, but accounts of the animals, or the products, or the wealth, or the customs of places up in what's now Ukraine, or in India, or in Arabia, or in Egypt. It's not just the first great work of history. It's also the first gazetteer. It's the first work of ethnography i mean essentially it's the first work of non-fiction and it is the acorn from which the say the great oak of what's now the internet
希罗多德的角度来看，还统治了非洲的大部分地区，这意味着希罗多德的题材基本上是整个世界，因为他将其视为一场世界大战。我的意思是，其实并不是。对波斯人来说，这其实只是一场边缘性的边境小冲突。但希罗多德将其塑造成了欧洲与亚洲之间这场伟大的战争。因此，这证明了他不仅可以写历史，还可以写关于现在乌克兰、印度、阿拉伯或埃及等地上动物、产品、财富或风俗的记述。这不仅是第一部伟大的历史著作，它也是第一部地方志。它是第一部人类学著作，本质上它是第一部非虚构作品，它是现在互联网这棵参天大树
comes okay the desire to comprehend the totality of human experience and kind of record it's wikipedia so let me ask a couple of practical questions do we have any vague sense of a date when herodotus wrote the histories? Yeah, several decades after the failure of the Persian invasion. So the great invasion that's led by Xerxes is 480. It ends at the Battle of Plataea in 479. We know that Herodotus speaks to people who had taken part in those events. And's incredibly thrilling because you're witnessing the birth there of historical method. Oral history. Well, talking of the Battle of Plataea, this great land battle between the Greeks and the
所萌生出的橡果。好的，那种理解人类经验的总体性并将其记录下来的愿望，这就是维基百科。那么我问几个实际的问题，我们对希罗多德写作《历史》的具体日期有什么模糊的概念吗？是的，在波斯入侵失败的几十年后。因此，薛西斯领导的大规模入侵发生在480年。它结束于公元前479年的普拉提亚战役。我们知道希罗多德与参与过这些事件的人交谈过。这极其令人兴奋，因为你在那里见证了历史方法的诞生。口述历史。嗯，说到普拉提亚战役，这场希腊与
Persians which ends in Greek victory and finishes effectively the Persian Wars, Herodotus speaks to a guy called Thassander who comes from a city of Orchomenus, which is kind of allied with Thebes. And Thebes is a great rival of Athens. And so the Thebans are on the Persian side. And shortly before the battle, the Persian general hosts a banquet at which people from Thebes, people from Orchomenus, Greeks who are allied to the Persians, share in this banquet with the Persians. And Tharsander has a conversation with a Persian talking about the prospects for the battle ahead, and the Persian is actually a bit pessimistic about them. And Tharsander remembers this,
波斯之间以希腊胜利告终并实际上结束了波斯战争的伟大陆战，希罗多德与一个名叫萨山德的人交谈过，他来自俄科墨纳斯城，该城与底比斯结盟。底比斯是雅典的强敌。因此底比斯人站在波斯一边。在战役前不久，波斯将领举办了一场宴会，来自底比斯的人、来自俄科墨纳斯的人、与波斯结盟的希腊人，与波斯人一同分享了这场宴会。萨山德与一个波斯人就即将到来的战役前景进行了交谈，而这个波斯人实际上对战局持有些许悲观态度。萨山德记住了这一点，
and he then talks to Herodotus. So this is as close to hearing a voice of someone who fought at the battle as we're ever going to get. And it's the first time you have that. It's the first time in recorded history that this is being done. So in a sense, this is the creation of history. And that's what makes reading Herodotus so thrilling is the sense that Schopenhauer said that everything that history will become is already there in Herodotus. And that's the fascination of it, I think. Okay. This is a bit like talking to Herodotus because you've got a Herodotian method of answering the questions where you're going to shoot off and tell me anecdotes and stories,
然后他与希罗多德交谈。所以这可以说是我们有生以来最接近听到参加战役之人的声音了。这是历史记载中第一次这样做。从某种意义上说，这是历史的创造。这就是阅读希罗多德如此令人兴奋的原因，正如叔本华所说，历史未来将要成为的一切，在希罗多德这里都已经具备了。我认为这就是它的魅力所在。好的。这有点像在和希罗多德谈话，因为你回答问题的方法很有希罗多德的风格，你会扯远并告诉我一些轶事和故事，
which is great, which is exactly how Herodotus was. Which is what he's all about. Yes. Exactly. So that's when it's written. Next, how is it written? I.e., what's it written with and on? I mean, that seems like a very banal question but i mean does he write it with he doesn't write on wax tablets or something surely he's well he's writing it in greek um it it seems to be written for oral consumption yeah so he he's probably giving he's he's reading it at festivals um the greeks are inherently competitive uh you know they that They cannot do anything without kind of organizing a competition. So probably that's what he's doing. And then he's writing it down as well.
这太棒了，这正是希罗多德当年的样子。也就是他全部的特点。是的。完全正确。所以这是写作的时间。接下来，它是怎么写的？也就是说，它是用什么写的，写在什么上面？我的意思是，这听觉上像是一个非常平庸的问题，但我的意思是他是用什么写的？他不是写在蜡板上什么的吧？当然，他是用希腊语写的，嗯，它似乎是为口头消费而写的，是的，所以他可能在发表，他是在节日上朗读它，
On paper? Papyrus, I guess. On papyrus. And yes, this was my other question. Why is he writing it? Who's he writing it for? Because if this hasn't existed before, what's the point of doing it? So it's for recitals, it's for competitions. So there's another tradition that he leaves Halicarnassus, he gets exiled, and he ends up in a colony that's been founded by the Athenians called Thuria in Italy, in Southern Italy. And if there's any truth to that tradition, then it suggests that he
希腊人天生好胜，你知道，他们不组织一场比赛就什么也做不成。所以这很可能就是他在做的事情。然后他也把它写下来。写在纸上？莎草纸，我猜。写在莎草纸上。是的，这是我的另一个问题。他为什么要写？他是为谁写的？因为如果以前不存在这个，这样做的意义何在？所以这是为了朗读，为了比赛。所以还有另一种传统，说他离开哈利卡纳苏斯，遭到流放，最终来到了一个由雅典人在意大利南部瑟里建立的殖民地。如果这种传统有任何真实性，那么这就表明
is being backed by the Athenians there. And he apologizes at one point for his argument that it's the Athenians who play the key role in defeating the Persians. So he constructs the first ever counterfactual, the first ever what if. He says, what if the Athenians had sided with the Persians rather than with the Spartans and the Peloponnesians? What would then have happened? And he says, well, without the Athenian fleet, the Spartans would have been unable to stop the Persians from landing troops all across the Peloponnese. And doubtless, the Spartans would have held out, but they would have been overwhelmed. They would have gone down. And so all of Greece would have been conquered. He's nervous about making this argument because by this point, the Athenians have become themselves
他在那里得到了雅典人的支持。他在某个地方为自己的论点道歉，即雅典人是击败波斯人的关键角色。因此，他构建了史上第一个反事实，也就是史上第一个“如果……会怎样”。他说，如果雅典人站在波斯人一边，而不是站在斯巴达人和伯罗奔尼撒人一边，那会发生什么？然后会发生什么？他说，如果没有雅典舰队，斯巴达人将无法阻止波斯人在整个伯罗奔尼撒半岛登陆军队。毫无疑问，斯巴达人会坚持抵抗，但他们会被压垮。他们会战败。因此整个希腊都将被征服。他对提出这个论点感到紧张，因为到这个时候，雅典人自己已经变成了
an imperial power. So in the wake of the Persian Wars, they are the great, you know, the saviour of Greece. And so they leverage this to make themselves basically the mistress of what initially is a kind of defensive alliance, but very soon becomes an empire. And it's this that leads to them in the end fighting with the Spartans, their erstwhile allies. And so the sense that the Athenians who have seen off the despotism of Persia have now themselves become despotic is part of the narrative. And it is also a theme that is woven into Herodotus' own history. The fact that he is standing up for the Athenians and the role that they've played in the war,
一个帝国力量。所以在波斯战争之后，他们成为了希腊的伟大拯救者。因此，他们利用这一点，基本上让自己成为了最初是一种防御性联盟、但很快就变成了一个帝国的女主人。正是这一点最终导致了他们与昔日的盟友斯巴达人开战。因此，曾经看到过波斯专制统治的雅典人如今自己也变得专制，这种感觉构成了叙事的一部分。这也是交织在希罗多德自身历史中的一个主题。他为雅典人挺身而出以及他们在战争中所扮演的角色的事实，
and the fact that there's this tradition that he ends up in an Athenian-sponsored colony, there's a tantalizing hint there that perhaps he's consciously writing it for an Athenian-sponsored colony, there's a tantalizing hint there that perhaps he's consciously writing it for an Athenian audience. Because by this point, Athens has become the great centre of literary culture, of all kinds of things. And in the terms of how people would, as it were, consume this work. So he would read extracts at festivals and things like that, but would copies be made of his original that would be distributed among Athenian nobles? Yes. So Herodotus has survived because, obviously, people copied it.
以及有这样一种传统：他最终落脚于一个由雅典资助的殖民地，这里有一个诱人的暗示，也许他是有意识地为雅典受众写作的。因为到这个时候，雅典已经成为文学文化和各种事物的巨大中心。并且就人们将如何，暂且这么说，消费这部作品而言。因此，他会在节日之类的场合朗读片段，但他的原稿会被复制并在雅典贵族中流传吗？是的。所以希罗多德能够流传下来，显然是因为人们复制了它。
Classical texts, by and large, if they survive, it's due to their popularity. And it's evident that even in his own lifetime, copies of the histories are starting to spread and spread. The evidence for that is Thucydides, who never mentions Herodotus, but it's an absent presence. The very fact he's not talking about Herodotus, and yet he's so clearly influenced by him. And again and again, he is making points that are clearly aimed at Herodotus, suggests that this has become part of the literary culture of Athens by the time Thucydides is writing, a decade or so, probably after Herodotus has finished it. So right from the start, the world's first two historians are sniping at each other.
古典文本大体上如果能流传下来，那是因为它们的受欢迎程度。很明显，甚至在他生前，历史的副本也开始四处流传。这方面的证据是修昔底德，他从未提及希罗多德，但他却是一个“缺席的在场”。他根本不谈论希罗多德，然而他却明显受其影响。他一次又一次地提出显然针对希罗多德的观点，这表明在修昔底德写作时（可能在希罗多德完成该书后的大约十年左右），这已经成为雅典文学文化的一部分。所以从一开始，世界上前两位历史学家就在互相冷嘲热讽。
Yeah, absolutely. Yes. And so it begins. But Herodotus himself, I mean, so the question then is, if there's no Herodotus before Herodotus, how has he got the idea for this kind of incredible project yeah and i think the answer to that lies in another region of the aegean which is the region called ionia of which the greater city is miletus but that you know there are other cities as well and they also have been conquered by the persians but they are the centers of what i guess could could legitimately be called the first great enlightenment. And this is the birthplace of philosophy in Greece. So Thales and Anaximander, people who are looking at the universe and trying to construct laws that would explain the functioning of the universe.
是的，绝对是这样。是的。就这样开始了。但希罗多德本人，我的意思是，问题就在于，如果希罗多德之前没有希罗多德，他是如何想到这个不可思议的项目的主意的呢？是的，我认为答案在于爱琴海的另一个地区，即被称为爱奥尼亚的地区，其最大的城市是米利都，但（你知道的）还有其他城市，它们也被波斯人征服了，但它们是我猜可以合乎情理地被称为第一次伟大启蒙运动的中心。这也是希腊哲学的诞生地。所以泰勒斯和阿那克西曼德，那些审视宇宙并试图构建可以解释宇宙运作规律的人。
And it's interesting that Herodotus chooses to write in prose because the first texts in Greek that are written in prose are laws, bodies of laws. And there's a sense, I think, in which the philosophers are trying to speak in the same way about the entire universe. So just as you would have a body of laws that structure how people should behave, say, in a city, what the philosophers are doing are trying to apply those laws to explain why there's thunder, why there are seas, how the world began, is the world the center of the universe, all that kind of thing. Is it round? All this kind of stuff. But that's what they're doing. And I think that Herodotus is kind of applying that measure, that approach to the dimension of recent affairs, of recent events. Although he's a kind of great narrative historian, loves anecdotes,
有趣的是，希罗多德选择用散文写作，因为希腊语中第一批用散文写成的文本是法律，即成文法。我认为，某种程度上，哲学家们试图以同样的方式谈论整个宇宙。正如你会有成文法来规范人们在城市中的行为一样，哲学家们正在做的是试图将这些法律应用到解释为什么会有雷鸣、为什么会有海洋、世界是如何开始的、世界是否是宇宙的中心，所有这类事情。它是圆的吗？所有这些东西。但这就是他们正在做的事情。我认为希罗多德是在将这种尺度、这种方法应用于近期事务、近期事件的维度。尽管他是一个宏大的叙事历史学家，喜欢轶事，
loves stories, he is also writing his history to try and kind of work out if there are rules that govern the patterns of human behavior. Yeah. And you said there was no Herodotus before Herodotus, but there are accounts, aren't there, of writers who had done non-fiction before. So I'm just looking at a list, Dionysius of Miletus, Hecateus of Miletus. So Miletus is the centre of, as you said, sort of proto-Enlightenment. And there are other people whose works are now lost, I assume, who are sort of writing nonfiction works. Is that fair? So Thucydides' pictures about Herodotus, and Herodotus, who generally from his work seems to have been a very genial man. People seem to have talked to him very readily,
喜欢故事，但他也通过书写历史来试图找出是否有规律在支配着人类行为的模式。是的。你说在希罗多德之前没有希罗多德，但确实有记载显示之前有作家写过非虚构作品，对吧？我正看着一个名单：米利都的狄奥尼修斯、米利都的赫卡泰奥斯。所以米利都正如你所说，是某种准启蒙运动的中心。还有其他人的作品现在已经失传了，我猜，他们在写某种非虚构作品。这样说公平吗？所以修昔底德对希罗多德的看法，而希罗多德从他的作品来看，似乎是一个非常温和的人。人们似乎很容易与他交谈，
and he seems a delightful man. But he has this Hecatias he clearly hates, and is endlessly dissing him. It's Hecatias who goes to Egypt, and a bit like Plato's account in Atlantis, where Solon goes and is laughed at by the priests, and he says, you Greeks are children. A similar thing happens to Hecataeus. He goes to the priests and he talks about his interest in genealogy, and the priests just laugh in his face because the Greeks have no understanding of the past at all. Herodotus says primly that I take no interest in genealogy, even though he does. His envy and dislike of Hecataeus clearly, as a predecessor and arrival, is something that's animating him. But there's no Herodotus before Herodotus because
他看起来是一个可爱的人。但他对这个赫卡泰奥斯显然恨之入骨，并且没完没了地贬低他。就是这个赫卡泰奥斯去了埃及，有点像柏拉图在亚特兰蒂斯里梭伦去那里并被祭司嘲笑的故事，祭司说：“你们希腊人还是小孩子。”类似的事情也发生在赫卡泰奥斯身上。他去拜访祭司，谈论他对家谱的兴趣，而祭司们只是当面嘲笑他，因为希腊人根本对过去一无所知。希罗多德假正经地说他对家谱不感兴趣，尽管他其实很感兴趣。他对作为前辈和竞争对手的赫卡泰奥斯的嫉妒和厌恶显然是激励他前进的动力。但希罗多德之前没有希罗多德，因为
no one is applying this to the dimension of the past. That's the key innovation. So what Herodotus is doing, he's not, you know, as it were, an archival historian staying in one place and pouring over the records, because you mentioned Hecataeus traveling to Egypt. The remarkable thing about Herodotus is that he's not merely the first historian. Am I right in thinking he's also either the first or one of the first travel writers? Because he's combining his history with ethnography, with anthropology, with travel writing, all these kinds of things. Because off he goes to Egypt and all these places. It does seem that Hecataeus had as well. But Herodotus is, I mean, he's exceptional as far as we can tell, because Hecataeus' works haven't really survived.
没有人将这一点应用到过去的维度中。这就是关键的创新。所以希罗多德在做的事情，他并不是（正如人们所说的那样）一个呆在一个地方查阅档案的档案历史学家，因为你提到赫卡泰奥斯去过埃及。希罗多德非凡的地方在于他不仅仅是第一位历史学家。我这样想对吗，他也是第一批或其中一位旅行作家？因为他将他的历史与民族学、人类学、旅行写作以及所有这些东西结合在了一起。因为他去了埃及和所有这些地方。看起来赫卡泰奥斯也去过。但希罗多德，我的意思是，就我们所知他是杰出的，因为赫卡泰奥斯的著作并没有真正流传下来。
Exceptional in the breadth of his interest in other places. So Herodotus was called by Cicero the father of history. But more recently, he's been called the father of lies interest in other places. So Herodotus was called by Cicero the father of history. But more recently, he's been called the father of lies. And a bit like with Marco Polo, did Marco Polo go to China? There are people who argue he didn't. There was a kind of a trend to argue that essentially Herodotus hadn't been anywhere and that the whole book is really a meditation on Greece and that what he writes about the Egyptians or the Persians or whatever are simply riffs on the Greeks. He knows about the Greeks and the Persians and the Egyptians are constructed as people who are not like the Persians or the Egyptians. I think that that
他在对其他地方的兴趣之广上是杰出的。所以希罗多德被西塞罗称为历史之父。但最近，他被称为谎言之父。这有点像马可·波罗，马可·波罗真的去过中国吗？有人认为他没有。曾有一种趋势认为，基本上希罗多德哪儿也没去过，整本书实际上只是对希腊的一种冥想，他所写的关于埃及人、波斯人或任何其他人的内容，都只是对希腊人的即兴发挥。他了解希腊人，而波斯人或埃及人被构建为那些不像波斯人或埃及人的人。我认为这
is clearly not true because what's happened over recent decades is that again and again, evidence has been found that kind of backs up what Herodotus is saying. And I think it's pretty universally accepted now that Herodotus did go to Egypt. Yeah. So what Herodotus will do is he'll be telling you a story. You know, he'll be telling you about the kingdom of Lydia, and then he'll go off on one about Lydia. You know, the kind of clothes they wear, the most amazing things to be seen in their kingdom, that kind of thing. The biggest one of all is Egypt.
显然不是真的，因为在过去的几十年里，人们一次又一次地发现了支持希罗多德说法的证据。我认为现在人们普遍接受希罗多德确实去过埃及。是的。所以希罗多德会做的是，他会给你讲一个故事。你知道，他会给你讲吕底亚王国的故事，然后他会就吕底亚发挥一番。你知道，他们穿的衣服，在他们的王国里能看到的最神奇的事情，诸如此类。其中最大的一個就是埃及。
So he's describing how the Persians are invading Egypt. Cambyses, the son of Cyrus the Great, the founder of the Persian Empire, he's leading this great army. They're invading Egypt. It's incredible drama. And then Herodotus says, Egypt is a land which boasts an inordinate number of wonders and possesses more monuments surpassing description than any other in the world. Reason enough then, I think, to describe it at some length and when he says some length he actually means enormous length yeah because it's you're girding your loins now for hundreds of pages yes you don't in any way begrudge it because it's herodotus who for instance who tells us about the process of mummification it's herodotus who talks to us about the kings who built the pyramids. He gives us all kinds of mad details about the
所以他在描述波斯人是如何入侵埃及的。居鲁士大帝（波斯帝国创立者）的儿子坎比西斯，正在率领这支庞大的军队。他们在入侵埃及。这真是不可思议的戏剧性。然后希罗多德说：“埃及是一个拥有无数奇迹的土地，其超越描述的古迹比世界上任何其他地方都多。”因此，我认为，有足够的理由对它进行相当长的描述。当他说相当长时，他实际上是指非常长。是的，因为你现在要为几百页做准备了，是的，你一点也不会觉得勉强，因为这就是希罗多德，例如，他告诉我们制作木乃伊的过程，是希罗多德向我们讲述了建造金字塔的国王们。他给我们提供了各种疯狂的细节，关于
obsession the Egyptians have with cats. He claims that Egyptian women stand up to pee, Egyptian men sit down to pee. It's full of this kind of mixture of clearly credible reportage and mad stuff. Well, he's making some stuff is made up, is just hearsay. So again and again, he says, so again, I'll quote him. Those who find such things credible must make what they will of the stories told by the Egyptians. My own responsibility, however, as it has been throughout my writing of this entire narrative, is simply to record whatever I may be told by my sources.
埃及人对猫的痴迷。他声称埃及女人站着小便，埃及男人坐着小便。它充满了这种明显可靠的报道和疯狂东西的混合体。好吧，他编造了一些东西，这只是道听途说。所以他一次又一次地说，所以再次，我引用他的话：“那些发现这些事情可信的人必须对埃及人讲述的故事做出他们自己的判断。然而，正如我在整篇叙事的写作过程中一直所做的那样，我自己的责任只是简单地记录下我的消息来源可能告诉我的任何事情。”
Right. And in Egypt, it seems that his sources are the priests. And what you have to wonder when you get stories about how the daughter of Cheops, who built the Great Pyramid, set herself up as a prostitute and raised enough money to build a small pyramid that stands in front of Cheops' pyramid, or when you get tales about how there are flying snakes that try and break into Egypt and they get beaten off by storks. And Herodotus claims that he's seen the bones for himself of these flying lizards. You know, what exactly is going on there? We can't be sure.
对的。而在埃及，他的消息来源似乎是祭司。当你听到这样的故事时，你不得不怀疑：建造大吉萨金字塔的基奥普斯的女儿如何将自己当成妓女，筹集了足够的资金来建造基奥普斯金字塔前方的小金字塔；或者当你听到这样的故事：有会飞的蛇试图闯入埃及，却被鹳鸟击退，而希罗多德声称他亲眼见过了这些会飞的蜥蜴的骨头。你知道，这到底是怎么回事？我们不能确定。
And I suspect that it's a mixture of words getting lost in the translation. Herodotus doesn't seem to have spoken any language apart from Greek. Maybe the priest's pulling his leg. Certainly having some fun with the Greek. They see him as a barbaric kind of primitive and they're just teasing him. Or maybe the priests themselves don't know. Or maybe Herod, as with the skeletons of the flying snakes, I mean, I don't know what he saw there,
我怀疑这是翻译中丢失了部分词语的混合结果。希罗多德除了希腊语之外似乎不会说任何其他语言。也许是祭司在开他的玩笑。他们把他视为野蛮的原始人，只是在逗他玩。或者也许祭司自己也不知道。或者也许希罗多德，就像那些会飞的蛇的骨架一样，我的意思是，我不知道他在那里看到了什么，
but maybe some weird graveyard of animals or something, mummified animals. I mean, it's hard to know. Or maybe it's Chinese whispers. He's picking up reports of reports of reports of reports. But that idea that he says again and again, you may not believe what I'm saying, but this is what I was told, and my duty is to report what I was told. I'm just the messenger. Don't shoot the messenger. That's what he's saying, right? Absolutely. But again, that is the historical method at work. He's reporting his sources. Okay, very good. So Tom, we will come back after the break with some of the most colourful and, as it were, the funnest details and anecdotes and stories from Herodotus. And you can pick out
也许是某种奇怪的动物墓地什么的，制成木乃伊的动物。我的意思是，这很难说。或者也许这就是以讹传讹。他一直在收集关于报告的报告的报告的报告。但他一次又一次地说的那个想法：你可能不相信我在说什么，但这就是我被告知的，我的职责就是报告我被告知的内容。我只是个信使。不要向信使开枪。这就是他在说的，对吧？完全正确。但同样，这也是起作用的历史方法。他在报告他的消息来源。好的，很好。那么汤姆，休息过后我们将带着希罗多德一些最丰富多彩、最有趣、最有趣的细节、轶事和故事归来。你可以为我们挑选
some of your highlights for us, and we can delve a bit deeper into the mystery of the histories. So we will see you after the break. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. During Darius's reign, he invited some Greeks who were present to a conference and asked them how much money it would take for them to be prepared to eat the corpses of their fathers. They replied they would not do that for any amount of money. Next, Darius summoned some members of the Indian tribe known as Kalatiai who eat their parents and asked them in the presence of the Greeks, with an interpreter present so they could understand what was being said,
其中的一些亮点，我们可以更深入地探讨《历史》的神秘之处。那么我们休息后见。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目和提前购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。在大流士统治期间，他邀请了一些在场的希腊人参加会议，并询问他们需要多少钱才愿意吃掉他们父亲的尸体。他们回答说，无论多少钱他们都不会那样做。接下来，大流士召集了一些被称为卡拉蒂亚伊的印度部落成员，他们有吃掉父母的习俗，并在希腊人在场的情况下（有翻译在场，以便他们能听懂所说的话）询问他们，
how much money it would take for them to be willing to cremate their father's corpses. And they cried out in horror and told him not to say such appalling things. So Tom, that's from Herodotus. Right from the start, he's a relativist, right? He's got a story about the Greeks who won't eat their father's corpses, the Indians who won't cremate them, and he's having some fun with that. I think it's so brilliant that you go for that, because I think that that anecdote is the absolute heart of his methodology. So the context for this story is Cambyses, after the enormous digression Herodotus has done about the Egyptians, has finally invaded Egypt and he's conquered it. And then according to Herodotus, done about the Egyptians, has finally invaded Egypt and he's conquered it.
需要多少钱才愿意火化他们父亲的尸体。他们惊恐地大叫，告诉他不要说出如此骇人听闻的话。所以汤姆，那是出自希罗多德。从一开始，他就是一个相对主义者，对吧？他讲了一个关于希腊人不吃父亲尸体、印度人不火化尸体的故事，他在拿这个开玩笑。我觉得你选这个真是太棒了，因为我认为这个轶事是他方法论的绝对核心。所以这个故事的背景是，在希罗多德对埃及进行了大量离题的讲述之后，坎比西斯终于入侵了埃及并征服了它。然后根据希罗多德的说法，
And then according to Herodotus, who in turn has got it from the priests, he goes mad and he goes around insulting all the Egyptian gods. A divine bull is born and Cambyses kills it. And Herodotus is really shocked by this. The reason that he's shocked, he says that everyone believes their own customs to be by far and away the best. And from this, it follows that only a madman would think to jeer at such matters. And this is Herodotus' coordinating assumption, that everybody's customs are precious to them, and that they all have different ways of seeing the world, and that people take for granted their own way of seeing the world. And it's only when they're kind of brought up against other ways of seeing the world that you can see how relative they are, how culturally contingent. And he illustrates this point with exactly the story that you told about it's Darius summoning
坎比西斯又从祭司那里得知消息，他发疯了，开始到处侮辱所有的埃及神灵。一头神牛诞生了，而坎比西斯杀死了它。希罗多德对此感到非常震惊。他感到震惊的原因是，他说每个人都认为他们自己的风俗习惯远远是最好的。由此可见，只有疯子才会去嘲笑这种事情。这也是希罗多德的协调假设，即每个人的习俗对他们来说都是珍贵的，他们都有不同的看待世界的方式，人们认为自己看待世界的方式是理所当然的。只有当他们接触到其他看待世界的方式时，你才能看到它们是多么具有相对性，在文化上是多么偶然。他用你刚才讲述的那段故事完美地说明了这一点，那就是大流士召集
Greeks who burn their parents when they die, and an Indian tribe who supposedly eat them. And both are appalled by the idea that they might adopt the custom of the other. And the lesson that Herodotus draws from this, he cites Pindar, the great poet, he says, this shows that custom is all. But I think that there's a further dimension that makes this an astonishing moment. Because what Herodotus is doing there is he is placing Darius the Great at the center of the story. And Darius the Great, he's the king who follows on from Cambyses. And he is the man who will send the expedition that gets defeated by the Athenians at Marathon in 490 BC. In a sense,
死后会火化父母的希腊人，和一个据说会吃父母的印度部落。双方都对可能采纳对方习俗的想法感到震惊。希罗多德从中得出的教训，他引用了伟大的诗人品达的话，他说，这表明风俗就是一切。但我认为还有一个更深远的维度，使这成为一个惊人的时刻。因为希罗多德在那里所做的是，他将大流士大帝置于故事的中心。而大流士大帝，他是继坎比西斯之后的国王。他将派遣那支在公元前490年的马拉松战役中被雅典人击败的远征军。从某种意义上说，
Darius is, for the Athenians, the bogeyman. But what Herodotus is doing is making Darius, the Persian king, the center of the story. From his perspective, the customs of both the Greeks and the Indians are kind of weird. It's the Persian who stands geographically at the center of the story. He's chosen Greeks and the Indians because they're both on the periphery of his empire. So Herodotus can recognize that to a Persian king, it's the Greeks who are the barbarians. And it's an absolutely kind of stunning insight. I hate to use the word liminal. Yes.
对于雅典人来说，大流士就是个魔鬼。但希罗多德所做的是让波斯国王大流士成为故事的中心。从他的角度来看，希腊人和印度的习俗都是怪异的。正是这个波斯人在地理上站在了故事的中心。他选择希腊人和印度的原因是因为他们都处于他帝国的边缘。所以希罗多德能够认识到，对于一个波斯国王来说，希腊人才是蛮族。这是一个绝对令人惊叹的洞察力。我讨厌使用“临界的”这个词。是的。
But Herodotus, he comes from a place that is on the edge of the Persian world, but also on the edge of the Greek world. So is he uniquely placed to be able to deliver these insights, to be able to understand context and stuff in a way that somebody born in Athens would not have seen this because they'd have said, how dare you question our customs? I think that must be the explanation for it. I mean, we don't know, but it seems to me the likeliest explanation for this ability to kind of basically think himself or at least attempt to think himself into the shoes of other peoples. Because I had an Iranian friend who was very kind of nationalist. His family had gone into exile in the revolution, and he had changed his name to Cyrus as a kind of mark of respect for the founder of the Iranian monarchy. And he hated Herodotus and refused to read him. And I keep
但希罗多德来自一个既处于波斯世界边缘、又处于希腊世界边缘的地方。那么，他是不是具备得天独厚的条件来发表这些见解，以一种在雅典出生的人所无法企及的方式去理解背景等内容呢？因为雅典人可能会说：“你怎么敢质疑我们的风俗？”我想这一定就是解释。我的意思是，我们并不知道，但这在我看来似乎是这种能力的、能够基本上设身处地为他人着想或至少试图设身处地为他人着想的这种能力的、最可能的解释。因为我曾有一个非常民族主义的伊朗朋友。他的家人在革命中流亡了，而他为了对伊朗君主制的创立者表示敬意，把自己的名字改成了居鲁士。他恨希罗多德，并且拒绝读他的书。而我一直
saying, oh, you must read him. He's wonderful. And he'd say, no, he's a terrible Greek who traduces the Persians. But he's wrong because Herodotus is hugely respectful of the Persians. He admires them as a people. It's Herodotus who records the Persian maxim that boys should be taught to ride, to shoot a bow and to tell the truth. And he records this as kind of very admirable principle. And even Xerxes, the Persian king who builds great bridges of boats across the Hellespont and lashes the waters when a storm breaks them and often behaves in a kind of hubristic way. A man who is so convinced of his power that he is committing the crime of going where he shouldn't, i.e. invading Europe, as Herodotus sees it. Nevertheless, the portrayal of Xerxes is often quite positive.
对他说，哦，你一定要读读他。他太棒了。而他会说，不，他是一个歪曲波斯人的糟糕的希腊人。但他错了，因为希罗多德对波斯人怀有极大的敬意。他作为一个民族很钦佩他们。正是希罗多德记录了波斯人的名言，即男孩应该被教导骑马、拉弓和说实话。他将此记录为一种非常令人钦佩的原则。甚至薛西斯，那个在赫勒斯滂海峡上建造巨大船桥、在风暴摧毁它们时鞭打水面并且经常表现得十分狂妄自大的波斯国王也是如此。一个对自己的力量如此确信以至于正在犯下前往他不该去的地方、即希罗多德眼中的入侵欧洲这一罪行的人。尽管如此，对薛西斯的刻画往往相当正面。
So Herodotus describes the vast scale of the Persian expedition, all the soldiers who are going on the invasion. And then he says that in all the millions of people on this expedition, there was no one more handsome nor better fitted to wield supreme power than Xerxes himself. And there's a very famous account when Xerxes, just before the invasion, he's still on the Asian shores before crossing to Europe. He is looking at his army. He's looking at his fleet. He's looking at his fleet. He feels this great surge of pride that he is the king of kings, the king of the world. And then suddenly he starts to weep. And his uncle who's standing by him says, well,
所以希罗多德描述了波斯远征的浩大规模，所有参与入侵的士兵。然后他说，在这远征的数百万人中，没有谁比薛西斯本人更英俊、更适合掌控最高权力。有一个非常著名的记载，就在入侵前夕，薛西斯还在亚洲海岸，尚未渡海去欧洲。他看着他的军队。他看着他的舰队。他看着他的舰队。他感到心中涌起一股强烈的骄傲，因为他是万王之王，是世界的国王。然后突然之间，他开始哭泣。站在他身旁的叔叔便说，嗯，
why are you weeping? Why these tears? And so his answer is, according to Herodotus, that he had been musing on how short his human life and the pity of it pierced me through. All these multitudes here, and yet in a hundred years time, not one of them will be alive. So that is a very Greek perspective. It's evident that Xerxes never said that. That is a perspective of tragedy. It's something that Athenian audiences watching Euripides or Sophocles would appreciate. But it is an attempt by Herodotus to sit on Xerxes' throne and to imagine, well, what would he think? How would he feel? So there is a kind of emotive effort there.
你为什么哭泣？为什么流泪？于是根据希罗多德的记载，他的回答是，他一直在沉思人类的生命是多么短暂，这种悲悯之情深深刺痛了他。这里有如此多的芸芸众生，然而在百年之后，他们当中竟然没有一个人还活着。所以，这是一个非常希腊式的视角。显而易见，薛西斯绝没有说过那样的话。那是悲剧的视角。那是观看欧里庇得斯或索福克勒斯的雅典观众能够欣赏的东西。但这确实是希罗多德试图坐上薛西斯的王位并去想象：嗯，他会怎么想？他会作何感受？所以那里有一种情感上的努力。
But some people listening to this, Tom, will say, I love history because history tells me truth, because history is a search for, it's a quest for the truth. And they would say, you know, in a postmodern relativist age, it's really important to cling on to these principles that there is a difference between truth and lies. And the idea of Herodotus, the father of lies, you know, seems to run counter to that. And the story that you're just telling there, Herodotus is writing, his book is not merely an account of following his sources, but it's an act of imagination as well, isn't it? As I think it has to be, because the effort of trying to think yourself into the shoes of different peoples for a Greek, I mean, I think for anyone, does require an effort of imagination.
但听着这番话的一些人，汤姆，会说，我热爱历史，因为历史告诉我真相，因为历史是对真相的探寻、对真相的追求。他们会说，你知道的，在一个后现代相对主义的时代，坚持这些原则——即真相与谎言之间存在区别——真的是非常重要的。而希罗多德——谎言之父——这个概念，你知道的，似乎与此背道而驰。你刚才讲的那个故事，希罗多德在写作，他的书不仅仅是对追溯其信源的记述，它也是一种想象力的行为，不是吗？正如我认为它必然的那样，因为对于一个希腊人来说，试图设身处地为不同民族着想的努力，我的意思是，我认为对任何人来说，确实都需要发挥想象力。
The reason that Herodotus is writing what we would now call history, nonfiction, rather than fiction, is absolutely because he's not writing myth. So at the beginning of his work, he distinguishes very clearly between the dimension of what we would call myth. So basically, unverifiable accounts that are often contradictory from a very remote past that can't be check up on. And he essentially is confining himself to what the sons of sons have reported. So basically, he's not writing about anything that's not 100 years before when he's writing it. So to that extent, he can't be certain that, as he keeps saying, maybe it's not true what he's being told, but he's reporting what he's been told. And when it comes to reporting what other peoples have said, obviously,
希罗多德之所以在写我们现在所称的历史、非虚构作品，而不是虚构小说，绝对是因为他写的不是神话。所以在他的作品开头，他非常清晰地区分了我们所谓的“神话”这一维度。所以基本上，那些往往相互矛盾的、来自非常遥远的过去的、无法核实的记述。而他基本上是将自己局限在儿子的儿子们所报告的事情上。所以基本上，他所写的内容，没有一件是在他写作之前100年内没有发生过的。所以在某种程度上，他无法确凿地说，正如他不断重复的那样，也许别人告诉他的并非事实，但他只是在报告别人告诉他的事情。而当谈到报告其他民族所说过的话时，很显然，
he's on slightly shakier ground because he wouldn't be speaking their language and he can't always understand the cultural frameworks and contexts within which they might be operating. But what's intriguing is that there are times where he will express doubts about something that he's been told, but at the same time, reveal something that suggests that actually it's true. So the classic account of this is where he reports the claim by the Phoenicians that they have been on an expedition sailing down the east coast of Africa and rounded it and come all the way back up and sailed through the Pillars of Heracles, the Straits of Gib and rounded it and come all the way back up and sailed through the Pillars of Heracles, the Straits of Gibraltar, and come all the way back.
他的立足点要稍微动摇一些，因为他不会说他们的语言，而且他并不总能理解他们可能在其间运作的文化框架和背景。但耐人寻味的是，有时他会对别人告诉他的一件事情表达怀疑，但与此同时，又会透露出某种实际上表明它是真的东西。这方面的经典记载是，他报告了腓尼基人的说法，即他们曾进行过一次远征，沿着非洲东海岸航行，绕过非洲，然后一路返回，并通过了赫拉克利斯之柱——即直布罗陀海峡、并绕过非洲一路返回，然后通过了赫拉克利斯之柱——即直布罗陀海峡，一路返回。
They've been commissioned by a pharaoh to do this. Herodotus says that he doesn't believe this for a minute. He says that one of their claims, which I personally find unbelievable, although others may not, was that while sailing around Libya, which is what he calls Africa, they had had the sun on their right-hand side. This, of course, is precisely the detail which enables us to know that the Phoenicians had crossed the equator. Yeah, fascinating. Yeah. So that suggests that when Herodotus is reporting stuff that he believes to be mad, it needn't necessarily be mad. And it also explains why when he reports the stuff that
他们是受一位法老之托来做这件事的。希罗多德说他一点也不相信这一点。他说他们的一种说法——我个人觉得难以置信，尽管别人可能不觉得——就是在绕行利比亚（这是他对非洲的称呼）的同时，他们一直把太阳挂在右侧。这当然正是那个能够让我们确知腓尼基人已经穿过了赤道的细节。是的，太迷人了。是的。所以这表明，当希罗多德在报告那些他认为极其荒谬的事情时，这些事情未必一定就是荒谬的。这也解释了为什么当他报告那些
clearly is mad, I think we should cut him some slack. So the most notorious example of Herodotus reporting something that clearly sounds mad is when he talks about how people in a desert in India source gold. And they say that the gold is dug up by giant ants and that the ants go down and they dig up the gold, but they're very kind of ferocious and predatory. They're dangerous. What the Indians do is they go out in the heat of the day when the ants are all sleeping. They grab the gold, and then they come back, and the ants chase them. They have to let go a camel so that the ants go chasing after the camel. This is absolutely the kind of story that has led Herodotus to being called the father of lies.
显然极其荒谬的事情时，我想我们应该对他多一点宽容。所以，希罗多德报告某件明显听起来荒谬的事情的最著名例子，就是他谈到印度沙漠里的人们是如何获取黄金的。他们说黄金是由巨型蚂蚁掘出来的，蚂蚁下去掘出黄金，但它们非常凶猛且具有掠夺性。它们很危险。印度人所做的是，他们在白天天气最热、蚂蚁都在睡觉的时候出去。他们抓起黄金，然后回来，而蚂蚁则在后面追赶他们。他们不得不放掉一头骆驼，好让蚂蚁去追赶骆驼。这绝对是那种导致希罗多德被称为“谎言之父”的故事。
What's going on there, India is part of the Persian world. And so therefore it's part of Herodotus' world. But it is amazing to think that someone in the Greek world in the 5th century BC could report anything about India, which is unfathomable distances away. And so it must be, I mean, what are these ants? There's a brilliant theory that maybe they are marmots,
那里发生的事情是，印度是波斯世界的一部分。因此它也是希罗多德世界的一部分。但令人惊叹的是，公元前5世纪希腊世界的某个人竟然能够报道任何关于印度的、远在天边且深不可测的事情。所以那一定——我的意思是，这些蚂蚁究竟是什么？有一个精彩的理论认为，也许它们是土拨鼠，
because there are marmots in certain regions of the Himalayas that go down and dig up holes and reveal gold dust. And the locals apparently did gather the gold. And you can imagine that maybe the word that is being used for marmot over the process of transliteration, as this story has reached the far end of the Persian empire, that it's become ant. And maybe it's been improved by the telling so that these marmots have been turned into kind of giant predators and things. But I think that you have to cut Herodotus some slack for that. I mean, he is doing something unprecedented. He is taking an interest in reaches of the world
因为喜马拉雅山脉的某些地区有土拨鼠，它们会下去挖洞并暴露出金砂。据报道，当地人确实收集了黄金。你可以想象，也许在故事传到波斯帝国远端、经历音译的过程中，那个用来指代土拨鼠的词变成了蚂蚁。也许它在讲述中得到了“润色”，于是这些土拨鼠就被变成了某种巨型掠夺性动物之类的东西。但我认为，对于这一点，你必须对希罗多德予以一些宽容。我的意思是，他正在做一件史无前例的事情。他对世界的那些角落产生了兴趣——
that are, by the standards of someone in a pre-industrial world, unbelievably distant. And what about the actual, what we would call the sort of the straight history, so the high political stroke military history, because obviously there he's competing with Thucydides, isn't he? And does Herodotus stand up well, do you think? Because is he really interested in that or is he too interested in his marmots and his ants and stuff? He is interested. So he gives basically most of what we know about the narrative history of what's called archaic Greece, so pre-classical Greece, derives from Herodotus. He focuses particularly on Athens and Sparta, because they will play the key role in the defence of Greece against the Persian invasion.
以一个前工业化世界中某个人的标准来看，那些角落远得令人难以置信。那么真正的、我们所说的所谓正统历史，也就是高级政治兼军事历史呢？因为很显然，在那方面他是在与修昔底德竞争，不是吗？你认为希罗多德经得起检验吗？因为他是真的对那个感兴趣，还是对他的土拨鼠和蚂蚁之类的事情太感兴趣了？他是感兴趣的。所以他基本上提供了我们所知的大部分关于被称为古风希腊（即古典希腊之前）叙事历史的知识，这些都源自希罗多德。他特别聚焦于雅典和斯巴达，因为它们将在抵御波斯入侵的希腊保卫战中扮演关键角色。
So our records of the dual kingship in Sparta, the early customs of Sparta, the succession of kings of whom Leonidas is the most famous, but he's integrated into a family tree that we can reconstruct thanks to Herodotus. Also the emergence of democracy in Athens. So the career of Solon, who is the person, according to Plato, who tells the story of Atlantis, the kind of great lawgiver. Then there's a tyranny. We'll be talking about this in a later episode, how democracy comes to Athens. But Herodotus is really our key source for that. And then you have the details of the wars themselves. And I remember when I was a child, Herodotus is really our key source for that. And then you have the details of the wars themselves. And I remember when I was a child, Herodotus was the first classic I ever read because I wanted to read about the Persian Wars.
所以我们关于斯巴达的双王制、斯巴达早期风俗、列奥尼达作为其中最著名人物的诸王世系的记录，都可以通过希罗多德重建的家谱追溯到。还有雅典民主制的兴起。比如梭伦的生平，按照柏拉图的说法，他就是那个讲述亚特兰蒂斯故事的人、那位伟大的立法者。然后是僭主统治。我们将在后面的剧集中讨论雅典是如何走向民主的。但希罗多德确实是我们这方面的核心信源。然后你便拥有了战争本身的细节。我记得当我还是个孩子的时候，希罗多德确实是我们这方面的核心信源。然后你便拥有了战争本身的细节。我记得当我还是个孩子的时候，希罗多德是我读过的第一本古典著作，因为我想了解波斯战争。
I'd become obsessed by them. And I realized that Herodotus is ultimately, you know, this is, if I want to know about the Persian Wars, I'm going to have to read Herodotus himself. And I spent the first four books of this vast work. He doesn't get to the Persian Wars at all. No, they don't happen for ages, do they? Yeah, absolutely. And then I got to the wars, the accounts of the Ionian revolt, when the Ionians rebel against the Persians, the Athenians support them. Darius is therefore
我对它们着迷了。我意识到希罗多德归根结底——你知道的，如果我想了解波斯战争，我就必须去读希罗多德本人的书。我花了这部宏大著作的前四卷。他根本还没写到波斯战争。不，它们过了很久才发生，对吧？是的，绝对如此。然后我读到了战争部分，关于伊奥尼亚起义的记载——当时伊奥尼亚人反抗波斯人，雅典人支持他们。因此大流士
determined to take vengeance on the Athenians, sends the expedition to Marathon that gets defeated. Ten years later, his son Xerxes leads this stupefyingly vast amphibious expedition. If Herodotus is to be trusted on the numbers, which he may or may not be, he certainly isn't with reference to the manpower, but maybe with the ships, it's slightly more accurate. And the Spartans get defeated at Thermopylae, the Persians then get defeated at Salamis, and the expedition is conclusively defeated at Plataea. And Herodotus tells this story brilliantly. It's thrilling and stirring. That's why the glamour of Marathon and Thermopylae and Salamis endures to the present
决心向雅典人复仇，派出了在马拉松之战中被击败的远征军。十年后，他的儿子薛西斯发动了这场令人瞠目结舌的庞大海陆两栖远征。如果希罗多德在兵力数字上是值得信赖的话——虽然他或许是也或许不是，他在兵力人数上当然不准，但在船只数量上可能要稍微准确一点——斯巴达人在温泉关被击败，接着波斯人在萨拉米斯被击败，而远征军在普拉提亚被彻底击败。希罗多德精彩绝伦地讲述了这个故事。它惊心动魄、催人奋进。这就是为什么马拉松、温泉关和萨拉米斯的魅力能够延续至今。
day. No one has made a Hollywood film about anything that Thucydides wrote, but 300 would be unthinkable without Herodotus. But it's not just the story. This is the first war. This is the first series of events that we can analyze as historians. Before that, we simply don't have the kind of the day-to-day detail, the day-to-day record. So yeah, I think it does hold up. So two questions about that, Tom. First of all, you said it was a stirring account. And of course it is. It's incredibly stirring and sort of rousing. And that's why 300 exists or any of the many fictional accounts of the Persian Wars. But we talked about Herodotus as a figure on the edge of the Greek and Persian worlds, able to see it from both perspectives. But these accounts, they are tinged, aren't they? I don't know whether
没有人为修昔底德写过的任何东西拍过好莱坞电影，但如果没有希罗多德，300勇士将不可想象。但这不仅仅是故事。这是第一场战争。这是第一系列我们可以作为历史学家进行分析的事件。在此之前，我们根本没有那种日常的细节、日常的记录。所以，是的，我认为它确实经得起检验。关于这一点有两个问题，汤姆。首先，你刚才说这是一份令人激动的记述。当然，它确实如此。它极其激动人心、令人振奋。这就是为什么《300勇士》会存在，或者说关于波斯战争的众多虚构记述会存在的原因。但我们谈到希罗多德是处于希腊和波斯世界边缘的人物，能够从这两个视角来看待它。但这些记述确实带有某种色彩，不是吗？我不知道
Greek chauvinism is the right expression. Maybe that's too loaded. But he wants the Greeks to win. I mean, it's very partisan, isn't it? Yes, it is partisan. But as I said, that doesn't mean that you don't try and get a Persian perspective, which is what he's clearly doing when he's interviewing Thassander of Orchomenus. The significance of Thassander is that he can give the Persian perspective on the battles. So he's doing that. And as I said, also, he is very aware of all the kind of the military and moral qualities that the Persians have, and even that Xerxes have, the commander of this great invasion. So I think that he is actually unbelievably balanced and fair in his account of the invasion to the degree that Plutarch,
希腊沙文主义是不是合适的表达。也许这个词分量太重了。但他希望希腊人赢。我的意思是，这非常具有党派倾向，不是吗？是的，它确实具有党派倾向。但正如我所说，这并不意味着你不会去努力获取波斯人的视角，这显然就是他在采访奥尔霍梅诺斯的塔桑德时所做的事情。塔桑德的意义在于，他能够提供关于这些战役的波斯视角。所以他在做这件事。而且正如我所说，同样地，他非常清楚波斯人所具备的各种军事和道德品质，甚至连这场伟大入侵的指挥官薛西斯也具备这些品质。所以我认为他在对入侵的记述中实际上达到了令人难以置信的平衡与公正，以至于普鲁塔克——
who is a biographer writing much later, kind of in the age of Trajan and Hadrian, he condemns Herodotus as a philo-barbarous, a lover of barbarians, a bleeding heart liberal, basically because he thinks that Herodotus has not been chauvinist enough. So I said how Herodotus is a bit like the philosophers, is trying to look for patterns, trying to look for laws. That was my second question. Are there laws that explain why the Persian Wars turned out as they did? So having said that he may well have been sponsored by the Athenians, there is a kind of quite a dark take on Athens in the histories,
一位生活在更晚时期（大致在图拉真和哈德良时代）的传记作家——谴责希罗多德是一个“亲蛮族者”（philo-barbarous）、一个蛮族爱好者、一个白左，基本上是因为他认为希罗多德的沙文主义还不够强烈。我刚才提到希罗多德有点像哲学家，正试图寻找规律、试图寻找法则。那是我的第二个问题。是否存在某些规律来解释为什么波斯战争会以那样的方式收场？所以，既然他很可能是由雅典人赞助的，那么在《历史》中对雅典其实有着一种相当黑暗的看法，
because what Herodotus is describing over the course of his histories is a kind of cycle that great empires rise and fall. And the very last passage in the histories describes Cyrus, and it goes back to the life of Cyrus the Great, the man who was founded the Persian Empire. And it describes a time where Cyrus has conquered his empire and delegates from his subjects, the Persians, come to him and say, now we're the rulers of the world. Why should we subsist in this rough mountainous area where the Persians have their home? Why don't we go down into the rich flatlands of Mesopotamia and settle there
因为希罗多德在他的《历史》中所描述的，是一种伟大的帝国兴起又衰落的循环。而《历史》中的最后一段描述了居鲁士，它回溯到了居鲁士大帝的一生——那个建立波斯帝国的人。它描述了这样一个时刻：居鲁士已经征服了他的帝国，来自他的臣民（波斯人）的代表来到他面前说，现在我们是世界统治者了。为什么我们还要在这个波斯人安家的粗糙多山地区艰难度日呢？我们为什么不搬到美索不达米亚富饶的平原上去定居，
and enjoy the fruits of our greatness? Cyrus says, well, you can do that if you want to, but if you do, you're idiots because he says, soft lands breed soft men. So there's this inherent idea that, and it's one that Ibn Khaldun, the great Muslim historian also fixes on that. There's a kind of inherent cycle where greatness results in softness and the people who have won this wealth are then unable to defend their wealth against kind of immigrants, newcomers, people who are from poorer lands who want it. And so the cycle goes on. But with Herodotus, there's also an additional sense that powerful people are driven mad by power and powerful empires are driven mad by power. So Lord Acton, power corrupts and absolute power corrupts. Absolutely.
并享受我们伟业的果实？居鲁士说，嗯，如果你想的话，你可以那样做，但如果你那样做了，你就是白痴，因为他说，温软的土地培育软弱的人。所以这里有一种内在的思想，这也是伟大的穆斯林历史学家伊本·赫勒敦所关注的。有一种内在的循环，伟大导致软弱，赢得这些财富的人随后无力抵御来自较贫瘠土地、渴望得到这些财富的移民、新来者。循环就这样继续下去了。但在希罗多德看来，还有一种额外的情感，即权势熏心的人会被权力逼疯，强大的帝国会被权力逼疯。所以阿克顿勋爵说，权力导致腐败，绝对权力导致绝对腐败。
And so this is a lesson that is manifest in the histories because the Persians win because they are morally superior to the people they defeat. They tell the truth. They are not soft. They learn to fire the bow and to ride horses. But by the time you reach the reign of Xerxes, his wealth is stupefying. And although he is a tough warrior, he is also clearly being changed by the fact that he can command the resources of the entire world. And it's this that leads him to his hubristic ambition to invade Greece and try and conquer Europe and results in his overthrow, which in turn has opened the door for Athens to become a great power. And I think inherent but unspoken in Herodotus' history is the idea that Athens is following
所以，这是一个在历史中显而易见的教训，因为波斯人获胜是因为他们在道德上优于被他们击败的人。他们说真话。他们并不软弱。他们学会了开弓射箭和骑马。但当你到达薛西斯统治时期时，他的财富令人咋热。虽然他是一个坚强的勇士，但他显然也在被这个事实所改变，即他可以调动整个世界的资源。正是这一点导致了他入侵希腊並试图征服欧洲的傲慢野心，并导致了他的覆灭，这反过来又为雅典成为强国打开了大门。我认为，在希罗多德的历史中，隐含着但未说出口的想法是，雅典正在追随
the Persian path. So in his histories, he's describing how Athens becomes a democracy. And he says that, you know, it's incredible the change that democracy brings to Athens. The Athenians, who'd never really done anything before, suddenly are able to defeat their enemies because they are free,
波斯的轨迹。所以在他的历史著作中，他描述了雅典是如何成为民主政体的。他说，你知道，民主给雅典带来的变化是不可思议的。以前从没做过什么事的雅典人，突然能够击败他们的敌人，因为他们是自由的，
because they are true to the kind of the ideals of this heroic new form of government. But, and it's this that enables them to defeat the Persians. But what everybody who's listening to Herodotus describe this knows is that even as Herodotus is reading out his histories or writing them, the Athenians themselves have become an imperial power. And although Herodotus probably doesn't live to see the defeat of Athens by Sparta, that is kind of baked into what he's writing. So he's writing as a warning? Yes, I think he is. And I think that if he'd known that Sparta would defeat Athens,
因为他们忠于这种英雄般的新政体形式的理想。但是，正是这一点使他们能够击败波斯人。然而，所有听希罗多德描述这一切的人都知道，就在希罗多德宣读或撰写他的历史时，雅典人自己已经变成了一个帝国强权。虽然希罗多德可能没有活到看到雅典被斯巴达击败的时候，但这已经融入了他所写的内容中。所以他写书是作为一个警告？是的，我想他是的。而且我想，如果他知道斯巴达会击败雅典，
he wouldn't have been surprised that very shortly after that, Sparta in turn gets defeated by the Thebans. And then the Thebans in turn get defeated by the Macedonians. And so it goes on. And then the Macedonians get defeated by the Thebans. And then the Thebans in turn get defeated by the Macedonians. And so it goes on. And then the Macedonians get defeated by the Romans. This idea that greatness is a kind of treacherous thing for people to win. So it's like Kipling's poem, Recessional, that you did at the time of Queen Victoria's Jubilee or whatever it was. One with Nineveh and Tyre. One with Nineveh and Tyre. Yeah, it's the same idea. But the joy of Herodotus, though, Tom, is that it's not just that, isn't it? It's that, I mean, it's all the things you've talked about.
他不会对不久之后斯巴达反过来被底比斯人击败感到惊讶。然后底比斯人又被马其顿人击败。事情就这样继续下去。然后马其顿人又被底比斯人击败。底比斯人又反过来被马其顿人击败。循环往复。接着马其顿人被罗马人击败。这种观点认为，对人们来说，伟大是一种危险的东西。所以这就像吉卜林的诗《离别曲》，那是你在维多利亚女王登基钻禧纪念日或诸如此类的时候读的。与尼尼微和推罗同归于尽。与尼尼微和推罗同归于尽。是的，就是这个想法。但希罗多德的乐趣在于，汤姆，不仅仅是那些，对吧？也就是你谈到的所有那些事情。
It's the tangents and the mad stuff and the travelogues and the weird characters and the folk tales and the legends that he can never contain himself to the story, but just kind of disappears off down various rabbit holes. Not unlike the rest is history, it has to be said. So do you have particular favorites? My favorite story is a story that I was told years ago by the guy who taught me Latin. And he was a very good drawer, illustrator. And it's back when there were blackboards and he had chalk. And he told the story of a man called Hippocleides, who was a suitor for the hand of the daughter of a very rich and powerful
是那些离题的话、疯狂的事情、游记、奇怪的人物、民间故事和传说，他永远无法把自己的思绪局限在故事本身，而是会顺着各种兔子洞钻进去。不得不说，这和《历史其余部分》（The Rest is History）如出一辙。那么你有没有特别喜欢的？我最喜欢的故事是多年前教我拉丁语的那个人讲给我的一个故事。他非常擅长画画和插图。那是还有黑板的年代，他手里拿着粉笔。他讲了一个叫希波克利德斯（Hippocleides）的人的故事，他是一个非常富有且强大的女儿的追求者，
tyrant, a kind of single ruler of a city. And because the daughter was so eligible, suitors had come from across the Greek world. So it was a bit like people coming to win Helen in the story of the Trojan War. They'd all gathered there. And Hippocles was, you know, he's doing tremendously well. He's basically out in the lead. So the tyrant, the father of the daughter is, he's requiring them to wrestle, to run, to fight, to read poetry, to do all the kinds of things that an eligible Greek bachelor should be able to do. And then at the end, he's about to announce that Hippocrates has won and he hosts a great
一个城市的独裁统治者。因为这个女儿太抢手了，追求者来自整个希腊世界。所以这有点像在特洛伊战争的故事中人们为了赢得海伦而来。他们都聚集在那里。而希波克利德斯，你知道，他表现得好极了。他基本上处于领先地位。所以那个暴君，女儿的父亲，要求他们摔跤、赛跑、战斗、朗读诗歌，做所有一个合格的希腊单身汉应该能够做的事情。然后在最后，他正要宣布希波克利德斯赢了，并举办了一场盛大的
banquet. And Hippocles is so excited and happy that he gets incredibly pissed and starts to dance on the table. And this is very infradig. And the tyrant says, what are you doing? And Hippocles says, I'm having a great time. Then he starts to dance on his hands and kind of wiggle his ears and shake his legs in the air. And the tyrant says, the way you're going, you're going to lose my daughter. You know, your bride is at risk. And Hippocrates says, and I paraphrase, Hippocrates couldn't give a toss, couldn't care less. And the tyrant says, you have danced away my daughter.
宴会。希波克利德斯兴奋极了，高兴得不得了，喝得烂醉如泥，开始在桌子上跳舞。这非常失体面。暴君说，你在干什么？希波克利德斯说，我玩得很开心。然后他开始倒立用手跳舞，还扭动耳朵，在空中摇晃双腿。暴君说，照你这样下去，你就要失去我的女儿了。你知道，你的新娘有危险了。而希波克利德斯说，请允许我意译一下，希波克利德斯根本不在乎，一点也不在乎。暴君说，你用舞蹈跳掉了我的女儿。
And Hippocrates just kind of collapses in a happy, drunken heap. And it just tells the story so well that it's, I think it's the earliest story that you can read and actually smile. It's funny. The first funny story in history. The first funny story in history. I mean, presumably, you know, there are stories that were funny to whoever told them, but the humor doesn't translate.
而希波克利德斯就这样瘫倒在一堆快乐、醉醺醺的烂泥里。这个故事讲得太好了，以至于我认为这是你能读到的最早的、真正能让你微笑的故事。这很有趣。历史上的第一个有趣的故事。历史上的第一个有趣的故事。我的意思是，大概，你知道，有些故事对讲故事的人来说很有趣，但这种幽默感无法传达。
But I always remember the kind of wonderful drawing on the blackboard that the teacher did of Hippocrates dancing on his hands and wagging his ears and losing his girl. And it's full of stories like that. Equally, there are incredibly dark stories. So there's a terrifying story about a boy who gets kidnapped by a slave dealer, gets castrated, gets sold to the Persian king. He rises to become a powerful figure in the Persian court, comes back and inflicts the most horrible revenge on the guy who had turned him into a eunuch and sold him into slavery. What does he do? Don't leave us hanging, Tom. No, I'm going to leave it hanging. You can read it in my Penguin Classics translation of Herodotus. I was just about to say, that is brilliant salesmanship.
但我总是记起老师在黑板上画的那些精彩的画，画的是希波克利德斯倒立跳舞、摇着耳朵、失去了他的女孩。里面充满了这样的故事。同样，也有极其黑暗的故事。所以有一个极其恐怖的故事，讲的是一个男孩被奴隶贩子绑架，被阉割，然后被卖给波斯国王。他一路高升，成为波斯宫廷中的权势人物，回来后对那个把他变成阉人并把他卖为奴隶的人进行了最可怕的报复。他做了什么？汤姆，别吊我们的胃口。不，我偏要吊胃口。你可以在我翻译的企鹅经典版希罗多德中读到。我正想说，这真是绝妙的推销手段。
Because if you want to find out the end of that story, Tom's translation of Herodotus, an acclaimed translation, it pains me to say, hugely acclaimed, Tom. Well done, I say very grudgingly. And I say that grudgingly not because I'm a mean-spirited person, but because I've got to do another bit of salesmanship now uh because all of this tom is in aid of your children's book the wolf girl the greeks and the gods it's not all in aid of it you i've been wanting to do herodotus you know ever since we started you have to be fair now tell us so you decided to basically set yourself up as
因为如果你想知道那个故事的结局，汤姆翻译的希罗多德，一本广受好评的译本，我很痛苦地承认，广受好评，汤姆。干得好，我非常勉强地说道。我之所以勉强，不是因为我心胸狭窄，而是因为我现在得做另一段推销了，因为所有这一切，汤姆，都是为了你的儿童书《狼女孩、希腊人和众神》（The Wolf Girl, The Greeks and the Gods）。这并不完全是为了它，你知道，我一直想写希罗多德，自从我们开始以来就一直想写。你得公平点，现在告诉我们，所以你决定基本上把自己打造成
a rival to herodotus because you're writing about the same period you are toying with herodotus aren't you a little bit he's the father of history this book is called the histories but uh your book as you have told our rest is history club members already ends with a feminist joke yeah her story because from a girl's perspective isn't it and did you do that deliberately because herodotus is it's from a girl's perspective, isn't it? And did you do that deliberately? Because Herodotus is obviously a man's perspective on history. I did it because, and again, I told the members of the club this, so they'll have heard this story before, that when I went to Greece to write Persian Fire,
希罗多德的竞争对手，因为你写的是同一时期。你其实是在和希罗多德开玩笑，对吧？他是历史之父，这本书叫《历史》，但是正如你已经告诉我们“历史其余部分”俱乐部成员的那样，你的书最后以一个女权主义的笑话收尾，是的，她的故事，因为是从女孩的角度出发的，不是吗？你是有意这么做的吗？因为希罗多德显然是从男性的角度来看待历史的。我这么做是因为，再次强调，我把这个告诉了俱乐部的成员，所以他们以前听过这个故事，当我为了写《波斯烈火》（Persian Fire）而去希腊时，
my daughters were very young. So my older daughter, I think, was five at the time. So I had to try and make her interested in all this stuff about battles and archaeological ruins and things, not always the easiest thing. And Gorgo was the only young girl to feature in Herodotus. And so I made her the centre of the narratives and a bit like Flashman pops up in all the key events in Victorian history, Gorgo in my version popped up in all the battles and meets all the most significant people.
我的女儿们还很小。所以我的大女儿当时大概五岁。所以我得想方设法让她对所有这些关于战争、考古遗迹之类的事情感兴趣，这并不总是最容易的事情。戈尔戈（Gorgo）是希罗多德中唯一出场的年轻女孩。所以我把她作为叙事的核心，有点像弗拉什曼（Flashman）突然出现在维多利亚时代历史的所有关键事件中一样，在我这个版本里，戈尔戈出现在所有的战役中，并遇到了所有最重要的人物。
And so the book, The Wolf Girl, The Greeks and the Gods, A Tale of the Persian Wars, is Gorgo is the narrator for that reason. Just to end with, not you, but Herodotus. Do you think, so is Herodotus still, is he the greatest historian? I mean, the father of history, but is he the best still, Tom, after all these years? Most readable, most fun? I think he's definitely the most readable. I think he's the most entertaining. And I think because he, you know, as to repeat Schopenhauer's aperçu that all of history is contained within his work, by that measure, he must be considered the greatest.
所以这本书，《狼女孩、希腊人和众神：一场波斯战争的故事》，戈尔戈就是出于这个原因担任叙述者。最后，不是你，而是希罗多德。你认为，那么希罗多德仍然是，他是最伟大的历史学家吗？我的意思是，历史之父，但历经这么多年，他仍然是最好的吗，汤姆？最可读，最有乐趣？我认为他绝对是最具可读性的。我认为他是最具娱乐性的。而且我认为，因为他，正如重复叔本华的精辟见解，所有的历史都包含在他的作品中，从这个标准来看，他一定被认为是最伟大的。
There you go. The number one historian, Herodotus, and the number two, Tom Holland, together in one podcast at last, and where I rank, God knows. So on that note- Well, you're Herodotian as well. Oh, thank you, Tom. Because Herodotus is interested in the full sweep of human experience. And that's what your books are. You give the high politics, but you also give space hoppers. Yeah, exactly. I just would have loved Angel Delight and space hoppers. Would, exactly. I would have loved angel delight and space hoppers. Would he?
给你。头号历史学家希罗多德，二号历史学家汤姆·霍兰，终于在一个播客中聚首了，至于我的排名，天知道。所以关于这一点——好吧，你也是个希罗多德主义者。哦，谢谢你，汤姆。因为希罗多德对人类经历的全景感兴趣。这就是你的书所做的。你讲述宏大政治，但也提供太空跳跳球。是的，完全正确。我只是会很喜欢“天使之乐”果冻和太空跳跳球。会的话，完全正确。我会很喜欢天使之乐果冻和太空跳跳球。他会吗？
I don't think either of us are Thucydidean. No. That's the kind of polarity, high politics, mad stuff about ants. And I think this is very much on the side of mad ants. And I think this podcast is as well. I think it's our Roderick Ian podcast.
我想我们俩都不是修昔底德主义者。不。那是那种极端的对立，宏大政治，关于蚂蚁的疯狂事情。我认为这非常偏向疯狂蚂蚁这一边。我认为这个播客也是如此。我认为这是我们的罗德里克式（Roderickian）播客。
Herodotus would have enjoyed the episode about pigeons, wouldn't he? Or the disastrous parties or any of the other. Best dogs. Yes. He'd have loved the Costa Rican civil war. Right. He absolutely would.
希罗多德会喜欢关于鸽子的那一集，对吧？或者那些灾难性的派对，或者其他任何一集。最好的狗。是的。他会喜欢哥斯达黎加内战的。没错。他绝对会喜欢。
I'm merely repeating what I've been told. Yeah, exactly. Right. On that note, we will return to Greece in a little while with the birth of democracy in Athens. But of course, we've got much more than Greece to come. We have things like the American War of Independence coming in July. We've got loads of fun things, rather like Herodotus,
我只是在重复别人告诉我的话。是的，完全正确。好了，说到这里，我们过一会儿将回到希腊，探讨雅典民主的诞生。但当然，我们接下来要讲的不仅仅是希腊。我们在七月有诸如美国独立战争之类的内容。我们有很多有趣的事情，有点像希罗多德，
ranging widely and credulously and credulously across the world. That's what the rest of history specializes in. So on that note, we'll see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
广泛而轻信地遍及世界各地。这就是《历史其余部分》的专长。所以，我们下次再见。再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. That's just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 restishistorypod.com。我们的会员俱乐部刚刚上线。如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集以及提前购买现场门票的权利，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。